welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
all right Jean I think we're ready to
start this show you got your jeans on I
got my jeans up I got are they tight
they're pretty tight they're pretty high
these are so tight yeah I put on a pair
yesterday and I was like I don't know if
I can do this today I'm not there this
is gonna be a maximum maximum Jean edge
let's do it ready before you have sex
you want to be horny for two or three
hours like you've never been in your
life you have access to marijuana too
good weed listen to me that go through
fuck are you dig dig too
[Music]
yeah that's good fief type and he goes
thief writes like that yes
Tamar Braxton so this guy what do you
think he's giving you sex advice I don't
understand what the advices so he said
if you really want to have super horny
like a good horny time okay he's telling
you got to get really good weed he's
telling you as he's inhaling laughing
gas through a balloon but now he's gonna
tell you the next thing to really up
your horniness ready true weed alone can
get you really hornier the normal but
it's been on drew take about 10 12
benadryl before you wouldn't have your
sexual fun with your partner or whatever
you do masturbate all right Tennant
there's no way too many so many I think
my heart would stop wait this is make
your heart I think also if you wanted to
tell anyone
hey you know any medication that's
over-the-counter take 10 or 12 of them
have sex that was really more intense I
remember as a kid my mother would give
me dimetapp your fuck good take take 10
or 12 shots of Afrin in your nose and
then smoke we make all right crazy I
felt crazy but I think the they're sooo
different isn't there in in that I don't
know anyway i used to take dimetapp as a
kid it's outlawed now it's gone it is
yeah because it was loaded with like
crank and I remember it just makes your
heart pound but I also had a Downers at
the same time so that you could fall
asleep so I'd be like like but you can
breathe real easy yeah yeah I don't know
man this guy he's got to figure it out
if you ask me I bet an hour later when
you feel it just kicking in smoke your
weed done and then go ahead and I
promise you it'll be millions and times
more you'll be so blissfully horny that
you will not want to come
yeah trust me millions is gonna be
restlessness if you take it really late
at night and you're and you wanted to
just go to bed don't do that
vinegar will make you have restless legs
and you'll wake up and you'll know it's
not very pleasing no it's not what's
going on those are my pupils I think
he's out of his yes is he filming in his
closet people's are super dialing he's
like can tell he's really honed it over
the years do 10 or 12 even come in the
foil you gotta get no backs to get 10 or
12 in then smoke your weed and trust me
there you're gonna be horny you're gonna
be all cranked up and then you're gonna
want to bring it down yeah
that's craziness dude it's a lot anyway
it's better than an orgasm
I've been up early 48 hours straight
before I'm in Underland weed
I'm not computer watching girl women
rustling yeah sounds good yeah sounds
like a good time women's wrestling well
and it's better than having the orgasm
cuz he's saying you're not gonna come no
he's saying you're not gonna want to
because you're so blissfully horny so
you're so so enjoying yeah what you feel
yeah you won't want to end it oh I see
you know you'll just want it to like
keep riding that wave riding the snake
yeah man
kind of lives too people have huh no no
man it's a lot of free time it's a lot
yes guys really worked out how do you
feel by the way Junior you're special
has been receives is pretty so
overwhelming it's so overwhelming to
have this much approval like I legit and
not used to people liking anything yeah
you know what I mean you just you slave
away in obscurity for 14 years and then
and you're just like it's fine I can say
what I want no one cares one day you're
like oh people care it's great yeah
it's amaze great special amaze thank you
well without without you my jeans would
never be so tight or high and me yeah
because you're my love you're my support
system you're my family or everything no
without you there is no Jean well
there's two mommies and one jeans that's
how it goes again if you haven't seen it
it's called machines with it and it's on
Netflix right now I actually had this
song in my head over the weekend a lot
of no I a lot it's not a bad song I feel
like it's not that bad I mean it can
take some work it needs work but it's
not bad it's pretty amazing yeah like I
feel like if the right band took it and
actually reworked it it would be very
good well we have a number of submission
of people that have reworked it oh my
god it's pretty exciting we also have
this email listen to the latest episode
of my way to work you guys suck and walk
around my office and machines within
machines within is stuck in my head I'm
trying to focus at my computer machines
within machines
it's like that juggle who tapped into
something inside me make it alright
Chris because I was laying in bed last
night and you were supposed to be giving
me head scratches which were inferior
because I woke up but my hair was not
tangled and but the whole night was
going machines with heat uh you know an
old fantasy about I had this and you
know I I don't know I do a lot of like
you know I do a lot of thinking you know
when I take like 10 or 12 benadryl no
but I'll come up with jokes and stuff in
the shower
I always thinking this yeah yeah and I
was this weekend I mean I was on the
road and I was doing shows and then I
was like I was like we should fly that
guy out bring him to like a friend's
studio yeah and like have a real
producer friend of mine lay a beat and
like film it that had this dude yeah be
and then one of my good friends who you
know is a music video director yeah yes
yes a video that was that would kind of
be the most amazing thing to ever happen
to this man yeah I think we should work
on you know let's find him
anyone know who he is let's find him do
you have any contact yeah does anyone
have contact from machines with any guy
because I think that could be I think we
need to make this happen we need to fly
them to LA and we need to treat him like
a star and yeah it's career doing
machines within you know I think we
could really do something special with
that I think so but in the meantime some
of our you know we are know a lot of
podcasts will claim you know their this
and that there are no there's no
podcasts in the world it has a better a
library and a better musically inclined
base than we do we have yeah some of the
songs you know the songs that have come
out of this show some of them are
incredible like there's really talented
people making music anyways I actually
was dreaming about this to this weekend
I first of all thank you to everybody
Ann Arbor in D and Northfield Ohio
Cleveland on real shows sold-out shows
really fun we just had the best time
right yeah and like we had great great
shows man they were just great energy
never knew Ann Arbor was gonna be like
that wait a min have a question did you
meet anybody after the shows like did
you take any photos of people or is that
just something a personality Jam does
yeah I took photos of people but were
you nice and stuff what do you mean was
I know cuz I've been getting reports
when I'm in I was in the st. loose Ted's
and and then South and people are like
Tom's not a personality champy doesn't
really meet people dude what are you
talking about right now
yeah you don't think I took photos with
people why would you even say it's the
word on the street that you're not
friendly you're not a personality
champion like I am what everybody was
like you're so much nicer than Tom at
least get me your fucking twinsies here
these are like three versions of the
same person's their Cleveland Indians
baseball players right here oh my gosh
play this it's all look the same came to
the came to the show Kip Zimmer
right here we hung out after the show
super nice high school yeah I took if
you go to my Instagram okay you're on
the gram I'm on the gram to the gram you
do the
again engagement so baby you go there
you can you can see all the pictures I
take with people um their pose
oh yeah but I have so many more machines
with it then machines with it all right
so it's not a bad song
I got a slight distraction but happen to
something there listen so here's just a
few but you just let me know let's see
this is a this is machines within
featuring Charo by DJ socks on the track
okay alright dude our listeners are so
town
[Music]
it's a different approach because here's
the thing when I hear I hear it was
interesting that you say that needs to
go that way but so this was just
someone's take on a so this is kind of
an it's a chiller it's a chiller bro so
I'm kind of scarier vibe yeah because it
had like an energy like horror movie
quality - yeah no t16 yeah
these machines this could have been in
the Sicario movie - right yeah right
coming up on the house
take like 16 benadryl
[Music]
I'm so happy Halloween Street Street I
like
but she did really good I mean so good I
should have done this too to remind
people but like this is what they're
working on
yeah trying to see my song trying to see
my song okay here we go here we go okay
I have another beat down for you I try
to practice practice my own song this is
my introduction to my song yeah coming
out you know here we go I'll sing it
shoots were thin machines in they've got
a gun I got against all our going up and
terminating their gun yeah machines but
this thing's worth it trying to rake my
rap trying to make my rap John dr. Simon
flow chime talk to someone full machines
width in machines worth this yeah
hearing hearing on the street I don't
give a f--- the haters all the haters
[Music]
good shit yeah DJ socks on the track man
very interesting take on it very
interesting take on it it's it's awesome
I applaud you I mean I can't believe you
that's amazing it's amazing what people
can do so this is machines within coming
up here by Equus yeah okay so this is
another version of machines within yeah
different take and yeah just you know
what do you like mastodons it's also
kind of a killer vibe right yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
again
what's t16 text the gun I don't know
what he's doing
just remember by the way because I
mentioned where was weekend I went to
this place in Ann Arbor called Freitas
Buddhist
it's like Cubans not true does buddy
does yes where is your toddler
restaurant no I'm famous what do they
serve their frito Bandito I'm thinking
they don't man at all what's it called
that's Beavis is restaurant let's go
Frieda patitos sorry I said yeah I went
here Frieda
patitos cuban-inspired street food oh I
it was so good man well I should see
this fried egg on top
Frieda anyways uh one of the guys
working there listens to our podcast Tom
ya know since our pom casts oh you're
kidding he you know I ordered the burger
and the egg and everything you know
I didn't eat I was like I'm not going to
eat the bun you know that kind of shit
right like you doing your primal shit
I just fuck anyway so they you know I
didn't know that he didn't say anything
at first so I order and then I had a
little side salad and then a server
comes out it was Tom and I go yeah and
he goes here's your kudos your fried
Cheetos like with sugar and chocolate
sauce to dip it in I go like to try it
and then I was like oh that's very nice
to you and then Josh Potter who's with
me
I was like you know I didn't order this
but I'm I'm not turning this down course
I just dove in yeah there's one of the
best fucking things I've ever hi little
judo bites
there's none the better covered in sugar
and then a chocolate a hot chocolate
dipping it's the second bomb dude I was
I had cramps for 36 hours after we ate
it and we had bites
we had cramps I was like I got feel good
later he goes well you ate just
spoonfuls of sugar like it wasn't like
sweet it's like covered yeah come on the
best fun that's what a you're saying it
wrong it's just true but right that's
how you eat a churro dude Judith it's
just a Mexican pastry now it's I said
but they're Spanish sorry the original
this is a Cuban joint but yeah it's in
Spain right I don't know they're Spain
Spanish from Spain I think they are I
watched the Great British baking show
and like look it up - those are from
spank and okay because they go this week
we're doing Spanish heroes of course
they can't say shit right on on that
show Spanish churros and they did the
same thing where they all had to do
variations on the cheer oh you roll
let's see a churro or traditional you're
right yeah you're totally right for once
in my life I'm right on the fucking show
yeah fried dough it's fried dough and it
comes out shot don't forget that there
is basically what it is it's basically a
version of a donut right but they're
covered in sugar it's the best and then
new shit is they give you a sauce to dip
it in yeah that's like the restaurant
it's like how we added bacon to brussel
sprouts
this generation everyone's dip in that
shit chocolate can I tell you the best
place to get a churro mmm to get your
life alvera Street in Los Angeles go
down Olvera Street one of those vendors
I mean that's what's up there all over
Latin America now anytime there's fried
dough the it's the best no one hungry
their version of the churro is called la
gauche and it's only in the summertime
you can get it and it's deep fried dough
then they put butter mm-hmm garlic mmm
sour cream and sprinkle some cheese on
that bitch I'll be good to get roll it
is so good
looks like they said there's they don't
know the origin yeah the story but they
think that maybe the Portuguese brought
it to Europe from China China so that
the Chinese maybe have well they do
because they have for it I'll tell you I
know this when I dated the Chinese guy
Chinese breakfast they do a fried donut
with like soy milk warm warm milk
another theory your donut is that the
true dough was made by Spanish shepherds
to substitute for fresh bakery goods
trudeau pace was easy to make and of
course I guess they brought it all to
Latin America because now you find it it
says you find it in Peru Venezuela
Colombia Guatemala so now it's
everywhere look at us and our knowledge
look at our knowledge okay back to
machines within machines within machines
so this is must genes within genes
listening by Benny Harper listening
again if if you need a reminder but
we're going off of here it's just just
where she's with them machines with it
that's it that's all these guys had to
work with amazed there we go miss genes
with it
sixty
pursuits with issues with him she's what
we're on the right track
[Music]
dear Sirs to
I say I don't think it's bad
[Music]
here
yeah Wow
[Music]
yeah pretty good man you know that we
have your mom's house we have fans that
are actual real like famous musicians
that listen to this yeah we have a few I
would I challenge those guys if anyone's
got some pretty I would love to see
someone do machines with machines with
in man I was really good yeah I feel
like Metallica if they could cover it
would be you know what I mean
oh yeah I mean they could do-- I feel
like they could come out with a
completely unexplained
the phrase machines within is fucking
really dope actually like oh that's kind
of deep and like yeah what is oh yeah I
do time what the man you internalize the
societal structures whatever the fuck
that means sure a lot going on there's a
look last uh last week you also were Joe
Rogan Spock that's right that was that
it was it was awesome it's the first
time I ever did the show without you
yeah so it felt a little bit like you
know on Seinfeld when Elaine you could
hang out George without Jerry yeah so at
the beginning I was like how's this what
I mean I obviously why does everybody
call you guys jeans okay we had a great
time Joe is such an easy person to hang
out with he's one of the one most
wonderful sweetest yeah with the jeans
funniest humans yeah and we had such a
great time we do it in a good time we
talk so much shit talks of shit isn't
that crazy by the way that literally I
don't know people totally understand
this but doing his podcast to promote
your special is more effective and
bigger than doing like a late-night on
many more people listen to it it is
bananas because I'm you know Netflix is
having me possibly do those circuits too
and that's like I okay but the truth of
it is the glamour is in those
you made under that but the years and
the focus is in the pocket the palm cast
what I've been getting so many tweets
from people that Joe Rogan referred me
to the special of course and now it's
like throwing so I'm very appreciative
to Joe for having me on as usual very
appreciative mommies put your jeans up
high and tight there you go
he's the sweetness masked so we have the
guide obviously tell us to take our
bandage drills and how many ten to
twelve and then when it kicks in then
smoke your weed okay wait let's go
through it seriously why is it so brach
Tober yeah cuz I'm gonna go to hot yoga
here in a little while
right is drinking and stuff is so much
not a part of my regular routine yeah
that I could accidentally slip probably
more than anybody else in other words I
put so little thinking and attention
into like getting a drink right that I'm
the one that could easily I feel like I
mean we're already halfway through the
month but easily someone could be like
oh hey I got you a beer and I'd be like
oh okay
in it yeah cuz you don't think about it
yeah I don't think about it like I
posted a joke this weekend after a show
Potter and I went to a hotel bar yeah
and I ordered a coffee and he ordered a
bourbon you know I drank my coffee but
yeah well I'll call it's not a big deal
for you getting high is not a big deal
for you no I know but then somebody was
like yeah but your drink you're not
sober because you're drinking coffee I
was like first of all decaf
straightedges it was like 11:30 I
ordered a cup of decaf just to have a
drink of something but that definitely
was not part of our arrangement was like
oh no caffeine which I did by the way I
did do no coffee for the last 10 days of
the weight loss challenge yeah that
sucks so bad okay I mean I mean you're
not Mormon this isn't them no I know I
don't want to do that shit man
caffeine isn't that bad for you
yeah I feel like I I couldn't live
without coffee
it's my what that is my one thing for
sure yeah I can't go with I love it I
love coffee too well I need it we have a
toddler how do you get through having
young children without drinking coffee
yeah I don't know it's fucking that nuts
so but but Joe's off the weed yeah he
didn't do it I mean he people thought he
was smoking weed but he's not he's not
no no he's fine
he seemed totally totally also a lot of
these things were not hard for everybody
for you too
now there's two other people in this
challenge who are not thrilled this
actually is much more of a challenge for
Arry and Bart they are there I can tell
it like I think Ari's more troubled or
bothered well definitely by not smoking
weed he's a really heavy weed you know
smoker yes
smokes weed every day so that's
definitely a challenge he hates the idea
of going to this class just because it's
an inconvenience which I can say I
totally understand it is a major
inconvenience like we're doing this palm
cast right now where we could be doing
it later but I have this and I have a
meeting and I'm trying to fit hot yoga
either like I can go either before the
meeting or after yeah I'd much rather
get it in before so after my meeting I
didn't come home because if I don't then
I have to go from a meeting to hot yoga
and then I'm home
fucking you know super late tonight well
cuz you guys are also doing 90-minute
class 90 fucking minute classes and 15
of them it's a lot of time commitment
especially because you're not just going
for 90 you have to drive there exactly
have to get your shit together go yes
now how sweaty do your nuts get it's on
I'm just actually it's when I'm done
with class it's like I just got out of a
pool yeah it's just I'm completely
soaked
now do you smell other people no people
are pretty decent you know I think they
show up clean and yeah you don't smell
people I think also because like to
smell someone would be either they're
dirty when they got there or you'd be
hanging out there way out you know I
mean like right he wouldn't smell right
away unless like one of the teachers one
time pointed out
hey if you're coming to this class and
you eat like a bunch of garlic before
you're gonna fuck with people like so
don't do that
so be a jerk don't be a jerk no you
should do take 10 to 12 benadryl and
then take this class yes super oh and
see if your heart just explodes see how
funny I am how horny I am in Canada now
I have to tell you that I used to take
yoga in Santa Monica yeah like a million
years ago and I always notice that the
men there's really not great yoga attire
for men like the women have all the
accessorizing supple dudes are in
speedos right like it's it's a bad
fashion they just haven't really
marketed it for men enough so I remember
standing behind certain gentlemen when
they would do the pose where you got one
leg on the floor and then one leg goes
back and up towards my keys amazed right
gets me yeah well your leg goes back so
you don't saying so one leg back one
foot on the floor and I remember seeing
countless nuts
countless balls and it's funny the first
time and then you're like really much
like you can't cover your nuts for this
class like you know your balls were yeah
I'm lucky I haven't seen balls I've seen
some weird dudes and then there was one
day where these two guys I was like
looking I was like the fuck is up with
these guys and then it hit me that they
were like developmentally disabled guys
oh and because they were doing like
goofy faces and they were acting goofy
like they were just acting weird and
then I was like oh I think they're like
maybe that bus brings him here you know
as part of a program or something and I
also notice that the teacher never like
the teacher will tell you know tell
people like all right Laura you got to
keep that left shoulder aligned Tom try
to roll forward further on your head
feet stay on the ground but these two he
never addressed and I'm like why isn't
he addressing these two goofballs and
then I realized that like oh I think
they're special you know doing retarded
yoga yeah they were they were kind and
one of them farted and now yeah yeah and
then one of them like was just playing
with his shorts and like and then
one of them just stayed on the ground
and wasn't really doing poses and I'm
like why aren't you like as if somebody
else you know I reached for water ones
not a water break Tom I was like okay so
it's like why are you not addressing
these two guys and then I realized oh
and when one of them showed up in khakis
and a button-down shirt and dress socks
and we were all like ah because it's you
know it's 104 degrees in there yeah and
then he left and came back in pajamas I
know if I I don't know what's going on
this guy like thick pajamas no like
regular but like still no one addressed
him yeah so that's what you do though
right give him a pass somebody of course
but I was like at first I was just like
what is up with these guys men you can't
really chastise them you know no of
course not no no
so they farted somebody farted yeah one
of the guys farted yeah did you laugh of
course but I kinda kept to myself you
know there's this like culture in in
Bikram where there's not a lot laughing
there's not it's all pretty you have to
you know you don't really get that much
out of it if you're not focused so
people even house Bikram okay be there's
not a lot of goofing off really yeah
that's so funny the most often there's
with was when is when Bert's next to me
you know like sometime
yeah sometimes you know we'll do that I
forget the plane pose we're like your
arms are straight out next to you yeah
you know yeah and then your end your
legs are straight back and I'll reach
over and I'll just like touch his arm
refreshes hand egg he'll look but then
I'll just you know I pay attention to
where the teacher is and yeah I do like
a little goofy shit like that but it's
pretty serious yeah we had any and light
enlightenment thoughts no not super
enlightenment but I deal I do say I mean
you definitely there sometimes you get
emotional in certain poses which is
weird it's interesting and I do think
you have amazing clarity at the end of
class yeah you know if you could when
you get through a whole class you're
laying there you your mind feels very
clear it's like you can make if you had
to like make a big decision
yeah I would go to one of those classes
and think about it afterwards interest
I like that that's exciting yeah it's
good it's good I mean I I do I do see
the benefit the only part that sucks is
with the bet it's like you just have it
like you know my week is crazy this week
yeah all right I sent you my schedule
because I have to go to all these
meetings and it's like I'm trying to
figure out how to fit in all these
goddamn sessions you know yeah and it's
the it's the time commitment the time
it's not like you can do it at home
either no you got to go to the class
that's the tough part yeah well you're
all you're halfway through it right are
we happy if I go to today what I'm going
we'll be number seven
and then I can't go tomorrow but I'm
gonna try to go Thursday Friday Saturday
I'm gonna try to go three days in a row
to tack on a few more and at that point
I'll only have five to do but I'll have
I'll have enough days to hit them now at
the end of the class do they hand out
thumb rings and like bracelets weird
guys the guys are all weird the girls
are the be some weird girls definitely
weird girls but there's some normal
girls
most of the dudes are odd yeah yeah
they're awkward they've got the bun man
buns there's a couple man bun guys a
couple yeah wrist band leather wristband
guys oh the leather cops yeah you know a
couple just patchouli salesman you know
just weird dudes weird shaman guys come
hugs
there's no dudes where you're like like
there's not a guy in there where I could
be like you see the game last night
right because they'd be like what game
are we time with a game of life I don't
know what they would say nobody looks
like they watch the game is everybody is
are all the guys like the goddess twin
activator guy but it's a bunch of us
yeah some of the instructors are God is
twin activators yeah we're like I can
teach you how to come hug you yeah it's
a lot of vegan vagina mm-hmm dudes and
now the girls are weird how what's their
style there's a couple like you know the
girl with like the third eye thing on
for her she wears like a bindi or
something here something like a sticker
isn't like hardcore vegan lifestyle you
know just like real grungy of the earth
weird in that sense yeah real spiritual
where you're like oh god you'd be
unbearable to talk to and there's I
don't know there's like some sweet older
ladies you know I go into there you
could tell like they're there
enlightened in life with age right there
like wise kind of cool some of them seem
like they're cool older ladies yeah I
mean you're definitely not getting like
a party girl
vibe in Bikram that's not lust of Bikram
and get wasted off you know there's no
there's nothing like that in there sure
a couple rehab chicks for sure you can
tell this is like part of getting their
life back together sure you can tell you
like you partied too hard before there's
definitely some of that you know that's
cool yeah so that's good everything it's
an eclectic Rob Roth oh man do you know
what if you started doing that during
Bikram well especially if you especially
on the gland penis gland pink is exactly
where I want to do it you know I wish I
wish he had some advice for for women I
feel like it's very penile I cannot
believe you just said that for people
that don't listen to this show regularly
Christina doesn't get the folders she
doesn't get these clips they're sent to
me and then if I want her to see one up
ahead of time I sent her to them so that
she knows but otherwise the whole fun is
to play clips and surprise Christina and
upset me yeah and now he has female
advice
see I know wavelength I feel like I
entered like I know this guy yeah here's
a rub up guy has tons of rubbing tics
for women isn't that great
that is nasty I'm not even sure I want
to hear you want to hear it so we have
it God okay we have the check for lady
to practicing in the vagina because the
vagina
the vagina or when you're too loose
especially the lay they have baby right
Maya that's kind of yeah my problem
we're not abandon you see there was a
nice small and when the baby hazardous
became true yeah yeah after that is well
loose right right she got loose purses
way talking loose baby comes out you got
a loose puss
so then what so when they make live
before them when they before they have
baby
they make them is so amazing so who's so
good after their baby when they put the
penis in the man put the penis in SA and
I in or out because to lose they don't
feel it I love his face am I in or out
Toulouse exactly how you felt after we
really am I in oh no you have to this
fucking no a bear trap yeah it's a snug
little it's like you guys okay it's like
you got little mouths in there going I
can't all right that women have to
practice their job the the exercise we
call it exercise okay but I guess I've
for the strengthening okay vijana give
them an egg and they practice like right
like crunch down on the egg
oh you put the Jade egg to shag you push
covering the egg and shit and you put it
in your leg
oh you put that Jade egg yeah sugar you
should hang you cover your egg and you
get free time now we we teach the people
in the workshop how to do exercise we're
important because woman when this baton
are loose the first or wrinkle but just
one type the first type how does that
how does that work but it make sense
shutters as you asked that question
watch Brian reason all wrinkled but this
one type the first title how does that
work yeah your stupid fucking yeah right
that's true it's a good question so what
he's suggesting is you take your shit
covered egg yeah you put it in your puss
okay when you push tightens your face
tightens
oh oh I see I don't know how that works
it's all connected your vagina is the
same as your face god damn it every damn
time
ha because when you lose you lose a lot
of sexuality our life ask or lick out
because it's playa flow or lie a big
door you know who enter your door is
leaking you use all the heat out and
look a week see that's why I'm so cold
all the time
because your doors open my leaky door is
Oh your leaky push energy door is open
if you tighten your post door yeah yeah
tight I got where do I get this shit egg
is he's selling those at the seminar we
got to go I got to pay for this man yeah
we have video can talk about massage
your testicles rub you dick 350 times
and now shove eggs in your puss I really
would love to watch them make love to
you I think it's an amazing experience
what is so nasty I mean it's different
it's not like it wouldn't be like one of
those hammer like pornos where it's like
some guy like gorillas pounding you this
guy would like really enlightened I
think you know you're you're always hung
up on this technique stuff as if that
negates the fact that he is like you
know even watch that show Battlestar
Galactica back in what's the show that
had sleestaks on there they're
constantly stacks
well the guy looks like a sleaze tag and
I can't get over it call me superficial
just close your eyes and let him tell
you to a wonderland the CREP it yeah but
you got way too concerned about reduce
dimension you have to reduce them play
that again because they're mental mental
mental very concerned about reduced
administration you have to be reduced
reduced amenity cars reduced what the
the mint Mentos Mentos straight a madman
presentation ministration regard
administration licking too much energy
yeah reduce my menstruation yeah how do
I do that
here you go what you reduce the amount
of yon astray so the reducing is the
massaging the breast there you go
every man a woman wanted her baby or not
her baby the body producing an egg every
man right and in a moment of producing
the body had to prepare energy to make
milk right right
wait a minute to make the milk but you
only make the milk if you have the baby
it's not that he's not understanding how
this works
you don't make milk producing the egg
this guy's got his science wrong I don't
know so I have to hold on in order to
reduce my menstrual flow to keep my
energy I have to rub my breasts during
and put and put an egg this is gonna be
a folded vagina yeah so big time
commitment Donna when this Vuitton I
lose the face or Ringo right yeah
but see how nice and wrinkle free my
face is yeah you look like you have a
tight puss that's how you can tell whose
vision is like yes that's a whole new
way of thinking about it yeah actually
that that'll never leave my mind again
like every time I see a wrinkled face
I'm gonna be like God tighten your puss
up your doors open yeah all the energy
is leaking out of your your box right
now
tighten your dog your door and then your
face will get nice and they'll be like
what you should bring this up at yoga
today yeah especially if I see a
wrinkled lady I'm telling you know if
this guy let's put this way if I took
his technique and I was like a nice
blonde lady teaching this shit to people
I could get on like the Today Show and
be like lady yeah you want to fix those
wrinkles that's totally you gotta
tighten your vision with him they're
just like this greatest wants a jerk-off
yeah it's all about the packaging yeah I
feel like we've talked about that with
jokes
it's like bits work from certain source
sure you know of course because you got
a from a certain person they can't I
mean they could say it but it's not
gonna have the same impact absolutely
absolutely it's all about the shell the
shell you're in definitely but I feel
like I could turn that into a seminar
and really make a living go do it go
make a bill
million dollars getting women's wrinkles
go away nah you know people still want
the wrinkles to go away that right away
they'd be like I see them some of my
wrinkles are gone yeah and you'd have
people testimonies like I went to
Christina's loose puss seminar and I had
wrinkles and now some of them went away
cuz my pussy's tight again like that we
could sell those eggs too
yeah you have your shit egg shit egg I
mean he doesn't talk about what don't
can an egg is break in your box
absolutely well theoretically when you
squeeze an egg on all sides it doesn't
break okay you have to have like a ring
on or something have you ever tried
sweet like you did in science class
right as a kid yeah I don't think he
means I hope he's not meaning a literal
egg that you would eat but like
something in the shape of one yeah like
one of LJ's eggs yeah your fig wine
yeah egg yeah are some moves that's a
big thing to put up there to pray I mean
yeah she's dude I don't know he didn't
know what the hell he's talking about
bullshit he doesn't know he so he's been
doing this for like 40 years he knows
what he's talking about that so when
they lady when when Lady and the egg
mature the breasts orden up because a
lot anything now when it's stuck and you
don't want them doing anything we did
you become lump and lump becomes tumor
and later on become we call cancer okay
he just solved breast cancer do you know
I didn't realize
[Music]
I'm miss Kay man what's she been up to I
wonder I don't know remember we had the
then we have that Kim and mash up right
yeah she's like I with the rub rub guy
and Kim in yeah together
Rob mi how do you say us how are you I
put a shit egg in my heart you say but
China by China make my butt Dana thanks
firm in this lovely house remember she
said that when she filled her porno she
goes we are here today I like that she
did yeah this lovely house and I have
two penis there no asshole I like that
we had the Kim in that she did a sixty
plus milf 60 press me off PC like a
clean version right and she did the
hardcore version right she did the
Youtube version so it wouldn't get
flagged yeah I'm like the the
advertisement for it I don't know why
they make them do too well to lure in
the perverts on YouTube
I guess and then the real one is on the
website it makes sense yeah you want to
get you casting the net for all the
perps yeah you gotta have you gotta have
them all there how'd you say and I'm
here to film that this is such a
beautiful Gemma Rossini with the first
time of my ever experienced in my life
with two young men and their big heart
this is the hardcore gym PluralEyes mark
yeah rocks plural really quaint place
quiet place is really really comfortable
retro is a lot of
artifacts that's what people are looking
at anything else really really
comfortable or being outside especially
with the two gentlemen who really treat
me very special my ultimate goal is to
really get them to be really really hot
and I feel that me came on everyone a
lot to offer
yeah oh you do yeah though it's my first
time I was a little bit shaking
what'd you think would be worse that
makes you think it would be it harder
for me to be with c'mon or for you to be
with this guy oh you would be kit you
would destroy c'mon why I feel like you
would like her so maybe she looks great
she looks better than me was fit come on
gents man no you be it you'd be fine
he'd this guy's a troll
Kim man's got her shit together at least
you think I could make love to come on
you would make sweet love to c'mon
I think I'd be way too gentle for her
she'll be like you don't pound ground n
pound
I think I'm sorry you don't wanna hurt
it what she would let you put it in her
butt all oh that would be like first
move yeah she'd be like wait what are
you doing there
get back there peg get back to the acid
really satisfied with my hope you seem
so nice yeah
she's sweet lady actually you think so
yeah save beautiful words I feel like
there are suitable words and a few
experienced and and I I was so hot for
them especially on the scene that they
put their hardtop I mean to my asshole
is ready to come I feel like it's weird
that because she's so she doesn't speak
like she's ever seen porn before I know
like do you have you seen the stuff that
you're filming I think I know what
that's a really interesting point and I
think maybe not yeah I think what this
is for her I really think she's one of
these people who at sixty was like I
want a new experience yeah and heard
about like well you can film that and do
all these crazy things and she went I
don't think she had like years of
watching it and knowing about it now I
think there's such a naivete there cuz
usually it's the guys being like what
are we doing today and then girls like
well I'm gonna spread my pussy and these
guys are gonna come in my mouth and you
know they know the jargon ya know and
she doesn't know this is really her
sexual liberation or whatever you know
yeah yeah yeah like well yeah yeah it's
usually a guy you had that clip playing
the other day we are like you're gonna
these guys are gonna come in your hair
and then you're gonna massage it in it's
like a cum shampoo I knew that right
all these guys all over the place okay
[Music]
we're doing this and Ash's gonna be
massaging to come into your hair okay
okay and this is really good for you cuz
I saw protein in the Hara yeah see
that's the average shoe film shoot yeah
she goes we have filming today she
really is not nice things they were
saying the artifacts yes she's like
sweet lady caress my body like I don't I
didn't see any of that and they're like
I take it cranny like nobody's caressing
do they any they hammer this lady of
course that's the whole thing the 60
press milf that you get hammered
who gentlemen gentlemen and I think she
learned the gentleman because of like
the gentlemen's club you know I'm like
they call strip bars the gentlemen's
club which is always silly like really
like there's guys in suits that are
showing up yeah what gentleman are
coming here and she probably she saw a
gentleman Club and was like oh these are
these are gentlemen yeah yeah yeah like
guys are interested in sex or gentlemen
yeah these are not gentlemen these are
not gentlemen I hate to tell you yeah
noctus for women as well there's a
mossad the breasts okay
massage my back forward backward and
shaking the breath and pushing the back
looking for what cuz he could teach you
this yeah and he I show you yes my yeah
I think I people pay me $500 I show up I
thought is ridiculous for them show me
the massage again it's crazy
Helena Singh Saab my stop back forward
backward and shaking the breath and
pushing the breast and pushing them
together
and that's gonna and that helps you not
get breast cancer right right right
just alluded to right right this is an
effective tool to the fiber I have to do
it does this had twelve-year-old boys
imagine like girls playing with this is
that 12 year old boys imagine what
doctors do like when you got a woman
goes I'm going for a physical I go and
play with your tits put an egg in your
puss uh-huh right
this guy's like yeah it's actually very
effective way to to keep a healthy body
going is this all one interview or did
this guy come back from IED that part I
don't know I feel like it's got to be
the same one and we just didn't absurd
he just found out about it look at his
dad shoes yeah those are nice Nikes
right there dad like you see yeah a
dude's got on like dress shoes yeah this
guy just went for his walk his morning
Tai Chi walk and then came to the
interview and you and then women so the
women probably take three to six months
to learn all these techniques much
longer than longer way and they have to
learn how to compute the contracting or
the uterus oh yeah acting of the uterus
London real you can watch their YouTube
channel and learn all about this stuff
and that's very very good information
yeah and then I got to do my urine enema
don't forget that yeah when this we're
gonna lose the face or wrinkle there you
go my urine therapy
I got a squeeze my egg I got a squeeze
my boobs
he's awesome I gotta take 16 benadryl
and then smoke pot and then you have fun
rock Africa yes I think it's gotta be
the same with you right yes and now you
do it as the same interview you feel
orgasm and really yes okay call orgasm
without ejaculation so you feel so you
see when you do when you watch it again
yeah when you squeeze is all guess I'm
coming up the interview are laughing I
know don't you feel like we should put
the benadryl guy and him together
oh yeah buddies like you super horny and
then he's like you smoke your weed you
get restless legs a massage we have two
methods that could go really well
together if you just thought about it
and you throw a man in there I mean it's
a perfect perfect mix perfect system
we've got the perfect the perfect smile
perfect system
it's really something Jane hurry up
what'd you do what I was going this week
rub my titties yeah play with my eggs
both your eggs
firmed it all up can't you see how
wrinkle free my shit is now yeah
hung out with little genes that good oh
he's the best dude yeah super fun hi all
the dogs I just showed i chilled really
hard I needed to be home for a minute
you know doing nothing that's my
favorite I've been baking lately and I'm
a terrible Baker because I watch that
British baking show and now I think I
can bake but I just fuck it up every
time but I still like it you know yeah
it's a good to do things you're not
you're not great at John Rogan I were
talking about that yeah he's he does
things he's not great I was like oh yeah
I think I'm started doing that now
because it's nice to to enjoy something
even though you're not good at it sure
and also feel like you can try to get
better at it yeah you know so LJ helps
me bake super cute and and yeah go to
the park run around take some naps
couple questions came in via email no
boy conjoined twins who wipes with
although recent curiosity about how
blind people experience certain aspects
of life I'm reminded of the many taboo
questions I have regarding conjoined
twins
I identify as an amateur scientist and
explaining my research most people wiped
with the same wipe dominant hand huh and
curious about wiping with conjoined
twins how do they argue about who's
going to wipe or does one twin always
wipe I appreciate any input towards my
research
it must warn you to try not to go too
deep down the conjoined twin rabbit hole
I think it's pretty dark thank you for
all the work and congrats on the awesome
Netflix special Christina jeans up hoes
down Steven Wow
well that's just I mean I don't think we
we would not know but we can put it out
there obviously to the universe well now
we've opened up a whole other can of
biscuits I know now we're in that
conjoined twins questions very I mean I
have so many questions for conjoined
twins I mean when it comes everything
everything how do you do everything how
do you decide what you do that day do
they go they separate people how does
that even how do you think no but that's
a great question God how do you like
someone the other person is there for it
obviously obviously so you're always in
an orgy like basically you both have to
be dating somebody let's say
theoretically and then you guys are like
everybody want to do it okay great
who what guy I mean I'm sorry or girl
needs two conjoined twins like I'm into
this I mean I don't mean it to sound
hateful but I mean really how it's too
hard just just logistically speaking
yeah not it you know just because you're
dating two different people basically
and they they have distinct
personalities so of course you're you're
always dating the sister and the
sister-in-law how do you get out of that
how can you get over that brother in the
Brethren yeah it's a lot how do you
masturbate how do you shit how do you
also with the master brain do you
realize that it could be like that like
my conjoined brother could be like I
could be like I'm gonna jerk off things
like I don't want to turn off like I
want to go to sleep I'm tired I was busy
but day tomorrow wait
I'm morning no and then you have the
same body partner fighting over I guess
in that case you let the brother do the
jerking and then you're just like why
just ignoring this yeah I mean the whole
I don't know I'm so set is that show the
show obviously isn't on anymore Britney
and Sally whatever it doesn't know
they're joined yeah but they don't they
don't answer the important questions not
any question that anyone wants to know
of course
there their questions were like how do
you guys deal with feelings yeah I know
I wanted to hear about that when you're
about blow job how do you take a shit
yeah how do you date how do you how do
you wipe God if a police officer has to
handcuff someone and that person is
missing a hand what do they do how do
they handcuff them is from Dave that
seems like something that Ackley's off
there's definitely police officers
listen to the show
you must have run into that yeah I
imagine they would cut a one hand then
you do the ankle thinks they can't run
away I guess the other hand maybe a hand
is too you know too dangerous to have
free so you got yeah you got a hank of
it to something but I want to I want to
know like if you're a cop and you've
ever been in that situation what do you
do you do you stick his hand down his
pants why would he do that just to be
like play with it down there we can't
have that out here handcuff his hand to
his dick and balls
that's silly Tom it's very silly that
could happen all these great life
questions really great questions
important question about calm hugging my
mommy's I show some friends the tip of
the come huggers
one of my friends raised an interesting
question if somebody come hugs you
without you knowing is that a crime how
many tantric rapers are out there Scotty
oh and his demonic wife creeped me out
thanks genes Jake take that very good
and she is demonic the the smile is
horrendous on that the cum huggers smile
so weird they're so so weak and the
answer is yes of course that's that's a
form of sexual assault
if you come hug somebody without their
consent yeah we practice Tantra which
helps us to pull the sexual energy up
our bodies so actually the longer we
make love the more energized we get yeah
right such a weird
I want her and the rub-rub guy and the
benadryl guy and come in in the same
room all of them that's a fun movie yes
that film they'd be like I really feel
like this is enough benadryl and that do
be like got a 10 to 12 10 or 12 the
whole movie would be about getting
people to take more benadryl okay 10 to
12 no it's not even even that possible
the Thai guys like to me too many too
many people yes for five minutes babe
that's so many benadryl you cannot take
that you would I would have a heart
attack that stuff freaks me out so badly
could you imagine
yeah half of that dose would kill me
half the dosage so much it's so much
you're so whacked out of your mind
they're totally crazy you gotta be crazy
to take that much no you shouldn't do
that is bad we should say that is bad
it's so bad advice and then to smoke
dope on top of that like what I mean
yeah no wonder your brains gone yeah
your might your everything is shut down
except for your peener
this is a we brought up you know
inappropriate parents talking about sex
oh you've had this Josh Potter has great
stories about this yeah
they got an email someone said hey I was
listening to your podcast 417 you
brought up parents talking about sex so
like also how like we never want to
actually talk in front of our son it's
it's so inappropriate to discuss your
sex lives in front of your children to
discuss any aspect of your sex what
person said wrong it prompted me to talk
about my 20 year long nightmare my
father passed away when I was a kid it's
my mom raised my brother and I by
herself when I turned 13 I started to
notice my mom becoming more and more
comfortable with innuendos ass it up
talking about the female anatomy I'll
cut to the chase and give you some very
low and loose scenarios here's quotes
from her I sweat a lot during sex
general talks about how when she gave
birth to my brother and I we destroyed
her vagina
one time when at dinner she ordered a
Sunday when the server asked if she
wanted a cherry she responded I haven't
had my cherry in almost 20 years
boy she has since remarried a great guy
they will talk about her sex life with
openly at the dinner table these are
just a few scenarios I have dealt with
in my life I agree with you guys it is
not right makes me so nauseous I can't
even eat moose soup anymore love you
mommies keep them high n-type Tom as the
personality champ HHM yeah I mean I I
dated you really went through it right
where is disgusting but my dad not my
dad my I dated a guy whose father would
make sexual jokes constantly yeah
constantly and that is just it's weird
it's so I remember disgusting other like
kids parents like that
my parents were hardcore the opposite
right zero right yeah I mean the most I
got what I would pick up on as I was
older my dad but doing a dad joke to
another adult in other words like it
wasn't for the kids right you know I
mean like right right somebody would say
a couple of state troopers yeah yeah
yeah but it was like it would be like
kind of like out of earshot yeah but
never like to us or like oh yeah used to
get real hard with your mom like that
like not is so gross no mine now it's
also like now I kind of I'm guilty of
like poking and prodding them to get
them but you're also you know almost 40
yeah yeah yeah and I'm like trying to
get it taxed you're asking for it my
mother when my mother passed away in
2015 we were going through old
photographs and my dad texted me and
sent me it copies of these photos he was
looking at he's like oh your mom had
great tits great ass I was like oh thank
you thanks for joining
that's why he married her good tits good
ass thank you is that that's the last
thing you want to hear about your dead
mom there's no greater tits in her ass
work yeah very attract your mom also had
like told you about sex when you were
really young yeah there was a lot of
that she I think she thought she was
teaching me teaching yeah that's the
thing is that she was
doing it in like a perverse you know way
but she was like you got to learn these
things right it was that she was way
ahead of schedule way I was like I was
about eight or nine or ten and it was
like she was giving me tutorials on how
to please men and this and that and I
was like you first of all first of all
is so funny my mother's biggest thing
was having a clean vagina you'll have to
keep your vagina clean and she had like
that old school douche bag like an old
douche with like the big red nozzle and
the black it was disgusting and then she
would she was obsessed with you have to
let your vagina breathe so at night no
underwear in the pajamas you have to let
your vagina breathe now my mother also
were nylon tights under her tight jeans
so of course I think she was strangling
her vagina all right she really needed
to let it breathe at night sort of a
curious lesson for an eight or nine year
old though yeah too early and then she
had edible panties that was the most
disgusting and it was by her bedside so
I think I was privy to her nightstand
contents you know like she would show me
what was in there and it was like this
is pina colada flavor I'm like what's
pina colada
like I was so young I didn't even know
and then I got to taste the edible
panties she's like it was it wasn't used
or anything she unwrapped it was like
you want to taste it and I was like all
right I thought but at the time you
think it's so cool cuz you're privy to
like map stuff you're like wow I'm mom's
best friend this is great I'm going to
fluid bond with Jesse yeah it was so
wrong like you're never supposed to be
your parents friends not even when
you're an adult you're never their
friends yeah you're always the child I'm
always gonna be I should always be a
child yeah you're always my parent so
nasty yeah oh it's so gross I taste she
Tate I taste them and I remember being
like this is not good yeah so gnarly God
so gnarly
just that do you have a hot sexy man
check lady my wife okay
that's my favorite part is the nervous
laughter that accompanies know these
horny people they're always nervously
laughing like what the the calm huggers
it's always this nervous laughter yeah
by the way we're always on the forefront
of you know weird speaking patterns and
yeah we had that guy from Texas yeah
that was the weirdest fucking guy ever
and I ended up he's all over Instagram
too and yet he has so many fucking you
know YouTube subscribers
hundreds of thousands is that crazy but
arcade in Dallas Dallas so weird
an arcade we dedicate this list to
everyone who has been affected by
Hurricane Harvey Harvey yeah I don't
know what how he heard him to speak but
his name's chills and hurricane Harvey I
guess the New York Times named their
first female editor oh and they did an
interview with her she is crazy vocal
fry' wait a minute there this is the
first female editor they'd had at the
New York Times I think so I think that's
what this 2017 right yeah Wow
yeah but I mean bananas chicks don't
read that's true you know it's very
meaningful to me that I'm the first
woman the executive editor of the New
York Times Wow
right cross-generational now and usually
you don't see it you see it in the young
women right you see it in the Kardashian
inspired women yeah I'm gonna go to the
mall and get some makeup yeah I will say
that I can go into it if I'm just tired
and I'm not like I almost said to me I
know I'm not supposed to ask this but
they'd ask me then a gender related
question I'm so proud of the fact that I
am the first woman to hold this job
Wow
Megan and I have been together for
nearly three years wild I like that his
grammar was proper there he said Megan
and I not me and Megan right that's true
so I am I'm partial to that kind of hold
this job doesn't even seem real talks
like that
this job I've never heard someone say
that I know you're the executive editor
for New York Times and you go it's a
good job I think yeah the biggest
challenge that I face as I prepare to be
executive animal is making everyone in
our newsroom as comfortable with this
transition that we're now well into and
I think maybe under my watch will arrive
at the other side and it's happening
it's happening I'm not saying shit bad
about the New York Times yes
they wrote a nice article about me so
I'm not gonna say this job yeah that's
true you were in the new yeah not saying
anything
well this the article is really good
it's basically I'm shutting the fuck up
right now I'm not talking shit about the
executive editor it's about the mom
linear mind comedy right being uh Ali
Wong and I are now were officially
declared a movement yeah it takes no one
a few other women are doing yeah but you
guys are really poor and Steven Seagal
is the latest to be accused of sexual
harassment bananas like a 20 year old at
harassment but oh no
yeah the 1996 that woman that's who the
picture was of were I pulled that yes
yeah she was in the wrong file she was
she wasn't to his house he summoned her
to his house to read for a role and she
showed up what she brought a woman a
casting director with her mm-hm and
Segal sat in a silk robe and watched her
do the scenes
yeah anything that said and then that
same day the manager called and said
Segal wants to offer you the lead but
you have to go back to his home for a
private rehearsal tonight No
and she didn't want to do it so they
offered her like a one Scene role
instead and cut her from the movie Wow
she said on set he would be like around
guys and look at her and snicker and you
know Wow ya know there you go that's a
man I am the king of improvising so yeah
so it's so it's so so odd I mean he's
usually such a normal guy yeah there
must be a new movie with him out by the
way because people keep sending me clips
of a new movie which is it's like
breaking down all the Segal walls that
we thought exists now wait a minute is
it on YouTube do we have a trail I think
it's on I think it's on Netflix but no
well I think his movies end up there
right we've watched a few on yeah but I
think he's got a new one where let me
see if this is kicky punch in the raper
yeah
his new one looks like a real hot pile
of shit look I fuck I just pulled up my
Ares there to area Mary Schaefer see
Steve he's got a new one Steven Seagal
you say that's not how you say it
I say Steven Seagal Seagal how do you
say it honey so Tommy what's a seagull
see gal it's gal wasn't us the goal
Seagal steven seagal even he's such a
weird dude man this whole thing about he
lives in Russia now right yeah I don't
know if they're alive no weird is it
there's connie's guys so many movies out
here I mean are you American or not
buddy you got choose a side you with the
commies are you with us man Asian
connection oh we watch that without
Asian connections fantastic word weapon
one star go ahead
Asian connection
good man I feel like we looked at that
one we looked at that one yeah is it
code of honor is this the one maybe that
he's why do all these titles sound
exactly the same
I don't know it's like Asian connection
code of honor man of words or whatever
they're all the same
they sent me there's just like sceneries
clearly cuz you know he's like really
good at improv
he clearly is improvising with the
actress oh and it's so painful you know
like poor girl is just like can I just
stick to the script and he's like you
can I'm gonna fucking just riff it's so
terrible he's he's just the worst
but yeah so now he's the latest to be
accused of harassment we're doing great
I love it I hope this trend continues I
would like to drain the showbiz swamp of
these creeps that would be fantastic
yeah I wonder who we're gonna find out
is the next big creeper cuz you know
once that once the can is open once it
starts make Hollywood tan wait a minute
wait a minute did you see how dark his
skin is oh yeah babe would you give your
life to save the world the world little
buddy know you do of course dumb shit
babies like brown there's a real actor
like I'm gonna try to act look at his
hair it's crazy he's he's so dark but I
can't I can't even get over how Brown
his skin is he's normally very pale he's
doing news new stuff every movie keep it
exciting man he's like that lady on
Maury Povich that we played remember the
Maury Povich lady who went black with
the injections yeah yeah yeah they might
be doing that he might be going towards
that I've been black now no you're not
yes I wish I wanted to hold me what that
fucking mumble was cuz it was amazing
but african-american my whole life he
goes I love the fucking cookies and
serious I love to fuck a tit cookies and
we know that yeah if anybody knows the
scene or the movie that that's in I
would really love to know as it looks
like such a pile of shit his acting is
really questionable I mean that was like
he does need to try I know let's see if
yeah that poor other actor was actually
trying to react and and have a moment
and and the Seagal was just like he's so
weird very weird dude very weird guy
lastly before we get out of here just
thought that maybe you would like to
check this out
maybe it's a direction you want to go
and as a parent Sweden is the most
forward-thinking country in the world
when it comes to questioning gender the
gender neutral pronoun hen is now
commonly used by most sweet yes yes I
love it huh
hen so I've just arrived in Arab brew in
Sweden I'm about to get me a family here
attempting to bring up their kids free
from all denned and all
this is Nico yeah what answered the door
what you'll see and not to be gender
normative here you'll see hand and
answered for sure yeah my partner goes
by Matilda and Matt but is also the one
who gave birth and I'm mapa
it's just what felt right to me because
I'm intersex I was born with
characteristics of both male and female
oh wow yeah got it all going on yeah
Dell is an American photographer who
moved to Sweden for love though what has
for over three decades focused on queer
identities and challenging gender norms
yeah this is Niko's room and how old is
Nico Nico's two and a half a metre it's
almost five in half Mika and Nico were
both assigned male at birth but in this
family the sexy were born with does not
dictate your gender identity there you
go we could have done something about
that ourselves do those were born with
male characteristics let's chill those
two those two were sorry born says
gender males I think so right is that
you heard no just that they're born no
is that what you heard I'm saying in the
that's what that's what they said right
yeah yeah they're born male and then
they're being raised a gender a gender
good idea we don't gender toys we don't
gender colors so whatever they're
interested in it's like they can just
play with whatever toys they want you
would never dictate what those tools
were no you're not so they both have a
lot of scars interesting
but interestingly enough she opens up
two drawers and all I saw were trucks
cars Legos traditionally boy things I
mean could that be because they were
born boys at birth I don't want I don't
want to be insensitive and what about
with clay things right now mica is for
the past two months has worn a dress
every day just about when Micah's
wearing dresses and because mica has
very very long hair most people assume
that Micah's female it which is what
wait a minute but that wouldn't that be
a gender norm for instance the long hair
he they hand just said the long hair is
traditionally feminine so isn't that a
gender norm no probably what happened
was that the child said I don't want a
haircut
oh my hair to be long we use he for them
sometimes it's mixed and it depends you
know because in Sweden we have hen the
gender-neutral pronoun in Swedish I
think Mika has always said when I've
asked it's been she or Ken oh there you
go oh so sorry so their child is asking
for XI or hen well then there you go
yeah then then that's what the kid wants
and you you know I feel like you're the
kind of leading communique are you don't
you dare don't you dare what am i daring
don't you dare get me to be the you are
the the binaries you are lot oh boy
you're that comic now people ask me
about the first 48 and bikes oh oh right
what's yeah yeah you're the person I
mean I don't know it's it's a I will say
that just watching our kid he's what are
you doing they've been our son has been
yeah privy to both dolls and trucks and
bike whatever Legos you know he doesn't
really care for the dollies and I try
it's not me but I don't know if that's
true don't touch the dolls home oh it's
not that it's that he doesn't care No
it's pretty and he likes dirt and trash
can playing and stomping in my hopin him
like it's pretty he's in the cars - it's
pretty Joe loves it yeah yeah how do you
avoid gendering your children you didn't
choose anything but gender-neutral names
we chose not to know what sex they would
be assigned when they were born not
answering the question is it a boy or a
girl to avoid the B word and the G the B
word and the G word how do you avoid
knowing that gender they're assigned at
Birth what does that mean you don't look
at their genitals I think knowing
beforehand Oh like caring that the home
for a boy or oh my gosh they would be
assigned when they were born not
answering the question is it a boy or a
girl
to avoid Edward in the giro what do you
do when people say is it a boy or a girl
see that's the answer I would like to
know right well I guess I guess it's out
to the child yeah
now here's my thinking here and maybe
this how do you handle a sweet old
person it's like girl why don't you mind
your fucking business why don't you
respect its pronoun it's a hen yeah I
think I also think that it sounds like
this person was had to deal with a lot
of shit growing up being both genders
yeah the intersex person yeah that's got
to be so horrible right to grow up with
your whole life since you were fucked
with and your kids probably wouldn't be
it's good to push your trauma on to them
exactly that's a really good thing to do
boys you should definitely be like I'm
gonna push my issues on you I mean yeah
and I get how painful that must have
been for them yeah because that sucks it
does but to go this far with this stuff
like maybe you just need to see a
therapist and then deal with her
changing pronouns in book instead of it
always being mama we say mama and mapa
what's the matter sweetie access mapa
it's so dark
she's a normal girl she but which one is
her son is it the one that they've been
interviewing no the other the other
parent I think so right
no because the other parent is the one
that gave birth Oh so the other one is a
female by so that would make sense that
that person would go to kindergarten in
a dress so I'm thinking it's the one
that's being interviewed right but then
she did have a normal old person
responses like it was fucking weird yeah
yeah meaning like I've adapted yeah and
that like my own son was not allowed to
do that yeah I mean look I I do feel
like this stuff these countries are
generally more progressive yeah there's
a lot this is a lot healthier society to
live yeah and then we catch up to what
they're doing in like 30 years yeah but
my stupid 41 year old brain is still
just like we not sure true I'm fully
confident they have like a way healthier
I don't know like criminal justice
system health care all that is way way
further ahead in Sweden and then yeah
that old region really yeah their
variant than Netherlands right isn't
that what that's considered no I don't
know what they are Scandinavia yeah yeah
they tend to be way more progressive
that you know in terms of the Western
world and what we are so much is because
she thinks I'm a great mom yeah yeah
well that's interesting you want to wear
this one or this one
you want this one okay we're gonna go
with the red and black theme today then
good idea see AMI on the other hand -
it's like you also are shape
how the kid responds to stuff you know I
mean yeah so it's like is it really
something that's originating in them or
is it because they're watching you do
your mom pop true cuz kids will just
imitate wet the fuck out of you men yeah
yeah yeah that's really it's an
interesting like it's a really
interesting question to ask if you're a
parent are just interested in how these
things work because the kid does all
kids especially when they're around you
alot your own kid they just go like you
start seeing they'd start behaviorally
doing things like you yeah they you know
I mean you see the way our kid picks up
the phone he's like wow yeah
starts talking the phone kind of like
imitating the way I do it yes it's just
they do what you do they do do what you
do it's faster day I do pong and that's
not something I always have to say pit
it would be good to know today through
the film this guy is a horn and ahem
just Miko okay CNN again are we
is this a lot of let's see that's a big
decision like first asking are small
personally yeah what do you want your
pronoun to be today and the kids like
how about just coming with my name well
doesn't that also rattle their cage in
terms of who their self is every day
right it's like well maybe this kid has
a an internal compass that's pretty
sturdy and your now you're cut you're
constantly forcing the questioning of
that compass maybe that kid doesn't have
the same stuff you did right you know
like maybe you're confused but your kids
not and then you're making them insecure
by being like well what's your pronoun
what's your pronoun whatever I feel like
it's such a heavy thing to try to break
down the person that would best answer
this question would probably be true
weed alone can get you really hornier
the normal but it's been on drill take
about 10 12 billion girl
where you want to have your sexual fun
with your partner whatever you do all
right feel like 10 or 12 benadryl would
solve the world's problem I think that
if you gave that kid 10 or 12 and
rolling like what's your pronoun
baby like I can tell you now and forever
it's fuckin hen okay and that's what it
is
there you go gene we got to go this is
our song murder boner by Big E thanks
for listening of course a reminder to
check out
Christina's special mother inferior on
Netflix streaming now I also found out
that my first special completely normal
is now available on Amazon Prime for
free can stream it there
that's cute Amazon Prime you can just
press play on it so I just found that
out and that's it that's what was call
me to see you guys next week what's
going on don't you
[Music]
the fact that the car kept going back up
the engines revving
[Music]
hold on laughing that confessions of
murderers you're laughing it true
suffered it's not me suffering that
gives you the tickle I mean everyone
gets excited about something